[Music]
question who's canada's
first drag superstar priyanka
yes i'm so excited
question who was the first ever queen to
walk in the drag race north of the scene
question what was the name of the queen
who went from toronto to north supreme
and so you know who it's gonna be
free you are a winner baby
congratulations
on winning season one of canada's drag
race i am so proud of you i loved
watching your journey
what went through your mind when you saw
that you had won last night
what's her name priyanka
congratulations
[Applause]
i solved that entire episode and i was
in a room
full of my number one supporters my mom
my brothers their partners people i used
to work with
everybody my best friends every every
drag queen that i've met along my
journey was there performing as well
and when when they when brooklyn said
what's her name
the whole room you could feel the air
got sucked out this journey was
so up and down it was so hard it plays
so many mental games on you
it's it's tiring dragon is hard
but drag is so easy in the same way too
and i just feel
incredible listen when i saw you walk
around the corner on that main stage
last night i literally i feel like the
air was sucked out of me because
you looked just so
beautiful you are the third queen of
color to win
in 2020 which is incredible
you are the very first queen with indian
heritage
to win in drag race franchise history
what does it mean to you to know that
there are queer pocs out there
who are watching you and see themselves
reflected
in you it's just wild that like this is
normal
like okay kool-aid went all-stars jada
won season 12.
and then i won canada's drag race like
it's just casual now and it's so
cool that like that's the normal that
that people can see
that people of color can win things and
and be the best
at that thing because we're often told
that we're not the best and you won't
get hired because
your skin color but my mom from the
minute i could talk
said when you walk into a room it
doesn't matter what your skin color is
you act like you are the one for that
job okay
it's really cool that now i can be a
voice to just normalize
all this stuff and and the girl named
priyanka can win and be the best
at drag your dad didn't know you were
gay
your dad didn't know you were a drag
queen he doesn't know that
i'm on the biggest drag stage in the
world
and that's heartbreaking because i want
him to enjoy that
for his child because i i know he'd be
so proud of me
you know since the show had premiered
you have come out to your dad
what did your dad say to you after last
night's win
i think my dad's in shock like my dad
just started realizing how much
drag race means to the entire world and
you know i'm letting him learn and grow
just like he let me learn and grow my
entire life i'm
letting him slowly understand what drag
is
he right now is like so you won
this show and i was like yes dad i did
he says wow
and then he like walks away because he's
still processing all of it like he can't
believe it you have to let him process
it he's still processing it and he's
he's proud of his boy i can tell you
that just be gay
there has been a huge debate this season
about the judge's critiques
specifically regarding jeffrey boyer
chapman and i really hated that a show
about
love has turned into him getting so much
hate did jeffrey reach
out to you at all i know he's been quiet
on social media did he send you a
message when you won last night or say
anything
let me check let me check my messages i
know stacy said congratulations
jeffrey said congratulations my queen
brooklyn sad well brooklyn for sure said
something
brooklyn sad
[Music]
what did brooklyn say what you got to
tell me now
i am screaming i posted this on my story
saying am i
the door and brooklyn responded to it
and said
what did she say i can't no
that is so brooklyn that is so brooklyn
what is the first thing you're gonna buy
with that hundred thousand dollars
priyanka
i think i'm gonna take some improv
classes
miss cleo coming i am so proud of you
you deserve all of this congratulations
thank you i did it i did it
oh hey there if you want more lgbtq news
and exclusive interviews
click subscribe or watch these videos